dershowitz formerly of Harvard author of
get Trump the threat to civil liberties
due process and our constitutional rule
of law Elder Schwartz joins us tonight
professor thanks so much for coming on
and with that introduction I do think
you're a credible
assessor of the case against the
Republican front-runner in New York what
do you make of it
well first of all I just got a tweet or
a note from Donald Trump himself in
which he endorsed my book or just
everybody to read it but he says Alan
enjoys saying I didn't vote for Trump I
believe he probably did he just uses
that phrase for added credibility but it
doesn't matter he's a brilliant guy and
you should read his book no I I didn't I
never mixed politics and and my
constitutional analysis get Trump is a
book about lying it's all about lying
it's about the four lies that have
resulted in four investigations
including doctoring a tape when which is
of course what the January 6 committee
did when it left out the words
peacefully and patriotically it's about
Michael Cohn who may be the world's
biggest liar he gets all the pinocchios
and the district attorney has making a
very hard decision now does he put his
bar at risk his bar certificate at risk
by putting on the stand the man he knows
is going to lie in violation of the
rules of Ethics so it's all about lying
my book get Trump documents lie after
lie the left the the so-called liberals
they're not liberals they're radicals
we'll do anything stretch the
Constitution destroy the Constitution to
prevent Trump from running for president
and it's and it's degrading uh to our
country and to all of us I appreciate
you writing this book I know you paid
quite a personal cost for saying things
like this
um and we appreciate it coming on
Eleanor Schwartz thanks
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight